bu insanlar nasıl değişiyor ne yapmaya
çalışıyorlar değişirken Nerede hata
yapıyorlar ya da gerçekten insanı
değişmesi mümkün mü bunlardan bahsetmek
istiyorum şimdi bu öyle bir süreç ki
baktığımız zaman bu güne kadar yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam tam bir rakam olmaz söz
konusu değil ama 14 bine yakın seans
yaptım psiko terapi seansı ve her insan
ilk geldiği zaman bana çanki eskiden bir
dizi vardır belki hatırlayanlar vardır
ni tak diye iki tane estetik cerrahı
hikayesini anlatıyor ve o iki Estetik
Cerrah masaya oturdukları zaman bir
hasta geldiği zaman ilk ona şunu
soruyorlardı nereni beğenmiyorsun nerede
değiştirmek istiyorsun diye değişim
sadece fiziksel olanı sınırlı değil
değişim Aslında kendimizle ilgili birçok
şeyi değiştirmek istiyoruz
alışkanlıklarımız yaptıklarımız
yapamadıklarımız' birçok şey aslında
değil
O sizin hep Odak noktasında oluyor ama
bu yola çıkarken karşılaştığım vakalarda
insanların yaşadıklarını yaptığı
hataları neden bazı insanların istediği
şeyler yapabilirken kendi yaşadığı
problemleri halledebilir Ken neden bazı
insanların yapamadıklarımdan bahsetmek
istiyorum sizlere şimdi ilk olarak
Şimdi burada şöyle bir Freud ve provida
seansta gelmiş bir tavşan bahsediyoruz
ilk başta zaten bir psikoloğun odasına
geldiği zaman artık çok pis kalemiz
yapılmıyor günümüzde Ama şöyle bir durum
var bir ip gidiyorlar odaya böyle
bakıyorlar diyorlar ya uzanmalı
koltuktan yok mu burada diye herkesin
bir obivan olan merakı var zaten bugünkü
anlamda psikoloji bize sevdiren insanlar
Freud oldu burada ekranda divana soruydu
temsil edin kişinin divanına uzanmış bir
tavşan görüyoruz tavşan şöyle bir
beklentisi var hayattan diyor ki ben
timsah olmak istiyorum hayattan
beklentim bu kendimi değiştirmek
istiyorum ve kendimi değiştirme
noktasındaki amacım timsah olmak işte
Burada freud'u temsil eden ki çok güzel
bir şey söylüyor Sayın tavşan sizi bir
timsah yapamayız ama havuçla aranızı
düzeltmeye çalışabiliriz işte öyle bir
nokta ki insanların birçoğu Bize geldiği
zaman yani bir
o geldiği zaman hep kendilerini olmayan
bir insana dönüştürmek noktasında ciddi
bir çaba beklenti içinde oluyorlar şimdi
üniversitede okurken İstanbul
Üniversitesi'nde böyle Pavlov'un Türkiye
temsilcisi temsilcisi diyebileceğimiz
öğrenme dersimizi veren bir hocamız
vardı o kadar böyle bilimsel pozitif
bilime önem veren birisi ki Nasıl oldu
da onu ikna etti birisi O zaman enelpi
çok popüler 2000'li yılların başı ve
birisi geldi demiş ki hocam Biz yeni bir
yaklaşım anlatacağız bu yaklaşımda en al
bir dersimizden 20 dakika bizi
ayırırsınız Neyse Hoca bir şekilde bunu
kabul ediyor ve o kişi içeri girdi İçeri
girer girmez böyle kocaman bir bağırarak
Merhaba arkadaşlar dedi Biz anlamadım
Neden böyle bir coşku dolu ses tonuyla
bize böyle bağırıyor diye Sonra ben
yandaki arkadaşa seslendim dedim ya
geçen hoca bak araya getireceğim diyordu
acaba öyle bir şey mi bu
daha sonra Neyse dedik izlemeye devam
edelim herhalde çağırdılar Sen hocamız
da buna izin vermişti vardır hocanın bir
bildiği Neyse bu kişi geldi sonrasında
olduğu yerde amfid üzerindeyiz olduğu
yerde geri bütün gücüyle ayağıyla
vurmaya başladı sevgili arkadaşlar dedi
yine bağırmaktan hiçbir şekilde
vazgeçmeyecek Burası dedi dünyanın dedi
en güzel en değerli ve en önemli yeri
Ben dedim ki kesin bakar örneği
şizofreni diyordu ona getirdi herhalde
sonrasında baktığımız zaman hepimiz
merak ettik ne demeye çalışıyor bu insan
neyi amaçlıyor diye ona baktığımız zaman
şununla karşılaştık dedi ki Çünkü ben
buradayım o yüzden burası dünyanın en
değerli ve önemlidir şimdi 90'lı
yılların 2000'li yılların böyle bir
kişisel gelişim ekolleri Biz hep şunu
zihinsel anlamda bir iş dışımıza
bilincimizin üstüne devamlı şu mesajı
verdi Sen hayatta ne istersen başarırsın
tavşan mısın Kimse
Bu elma ağacı mısın Kiraz verebilirsin
hiç sorun değil hep ikinci işte
yeterince istersen her şeyi başarırsın
bir Eğer baş Aramıyorsan yeterince
istemiyorsun Dur bu da başlı başına bir
psikolojik problem ve bugün kendini
değiştirme kendini geliştirme sektörü
dünyayı baz aldığımız zaman başta
Amerika'nın başı çektiği şekilde milyar
dolarlık bir sektör Herkes kendini
değiştirmek istiyor Herkes bir şekilde
olduğu yerden memnun değil huzursuz
gerginiz ve Böyle bir durumda ne olacak
insanlar hep yeni yaklaşımlar ortaya
çıkartıyor bir danışanım yakın zamanda
bana geldiği zaman şöyle bir şey dedi
Hocam dedi bana dedi zarar veren bir
ilişkim vardı ve o zamanlar çok popüler
olan bir isme gittim şöyle bir şey
yapıyormuş bilinçaltı sıfırlama tekniği
uzmanı ve böylece böyle bir mesleğin
doğmuş olduğunu ondan Öğrenmiş oldum ben
Neyse dedim Ne yaptınız işte de eski
sevgilimi unutmaya çalıştık ve bir süre
devam
bir yıllık bir süreç boyunca Ben yardım
almaya devam ettim bu kişiden peki dedim
Ne oldu biz evlendik O kişiyle dedi
O bizim başarılı olmuş ama tersten
başarılı olmuş şimdi kendimizi
değiştirmeye çalışırken böyle de bir
sektör varken bu sektörün tuzağına
düşmek ciddi anlamda mümkün Peki işin
efsanesinden uzaklaşarak İnsan gerçekten
Kendisi değiştirebilirmi bu heykeli
bilenler vardır belki görenler vardır
Ben yakından görmedim ama gören
arkadaşlarım oldu ve gören insanların
internette yazdığı yorumları okudum bu
yorumlarda genelde şöyle bir şeyden
bahsediyorlar o kadar canlı Bir heykel
ki bu mikelenjelonun Musa heykeli
gördüğünüz zaman bu heykeli yakından şu
anki dokunduğun zaman canlanacak mış
gibi bir hissiyata kapılıyorsunuz bu no
kadar canlı o kadar ustalıklı belki de
bir heykel sanatının gelebileceği en
güzel nokta ve mikelenjelonun bu kadar
başarılı ve yeni şeyler ortaya
çıkarmasından sonra 3 tat diyorlar Sen
bu kadar güzel heykelleri
o kadar güzel eserleri nasıl yapıyorsun
Nasıl başarıyorsun
o orada büyük enerjisa'nın cevabı Bence
efsane şöyle bir şey söylüyor Ben hiçbir
şey yapmıyorum ki heykel taşın içinde
saklı zaten Ben sadece fazlalıkları
atıyorum taşın üzerindeki ne oluyor o
fazlalıkları atınca taşın içindeki o
güzel heykel karşımıza çıkıyor işte
insanın kendini değiştirme noktasında
karşılaşacağı en büyük açmaz ve
vermedikleri gereken en büyük karar bu
yani dışarıda başka bir elbise alarak
Başka bir ülkede yaşayarak Başka Bir
Şehirde yaşayarak ya da başka bir
insanla birlikte olarak kendini
değiştiremiyor Sun sadece eğer
değiştirmek istiyorsan kendinden kendine
gidebildiğim yolu keşfe de bilmen
gerekiyor ve burada mikelenjelonun o
sözünü hatırlamakta fayda var peki
değişim yoluna çıkıyoruz insanlar
nelerle karşılaşıyor ne gibi problemler
Görüyor da bu süreç
bu gizli engelleniyor ilk başta
karşılaştığım şeylerden birisi bir süre
engelli var ben sadece burada üç
tanesinden bahsedeceğim sizlere duygusal
engeller çocukluğumuzdan getirdiğimiz
İçinde bulunduğumuz durum var vesaire
hepsi bizim Aslında her biz dünyanın en
güzel kadını en yakışıklı erkeği de
olsak İçinde bulunduğumuz durumdan
dolayı ailemiz çevremiz bize çirkin
a**** yetersiz olduğunuzu söylüyorsa Biz
ne kadar başarılı olursak olalım ne
kadar iyi yerlere gelirsek gelelim
içimizde hep bir şekilde yapamadığımız
da yönelik bilgisi yat oluşuyor Şimdi
burada bu duygu ve düşünce ayrımını
anlamamız çok önemli ben hep bu anı
bekliyordum İzmir'de bir etkinlik olsada
izmirlere bir çatsam diye benim çok
sevdiğim İzmir bir arkadaşım var
Ankara'da niyeyse bu izmirlilerin Ankara
yakıcı var
var ya işte geliyor böyle ya bu
Ankara'nın duvarları gri insanların yüzü
asık herkes memur gökyüzü Bilo gri
Asfalt bile gri her zaman böyle bir
havada civata geziyor böyle Ben de
diyorum ki Ankara'da sana bayılıyorum
Siz izmirlere bayılıyordu sanki Neyse
aradan uzun bir dostluğumuz var bu
kişiyle bir gün geldi bana ama böyle
filmlerdeki böyle hoplaya hoplaya koşma
hali var ya o şekilde geliyor yani
Beyhan dedi Ankara'nın dedi Taşı toprağı
bile bir farklı grisi var çok güzel çok
farklı gökyüzünün grisi ve bana bir
şekilde farklı geliyor Ankara ne
güzelmiş thebaine fark edememişim
Ankara'nın güzelliğin dedi hem de
içimden dedim ki farketti doğru yolu
buldu gibi bir hissiyat var Ama tabii
işin aslı bu değil dedim lan yoksa Aşık
mı oldun sen
Sen nereden anladın boşuna mı psikolog
olduk dedim bakış attım Tabii öyle değil
şimdi buradaki mevzu çok önemli bir
durum Aslında hissettiğimiz şeyler
gerçeğimiz olmayabilir Ankara aynı
Ankara bugün aynanın karşısına bakıyorum
yorum ki ya diyorum Kim bu yakışıklı a
Benmişim şu Kaşların güzelliğine bak
diyorum ya Allahım yarabbim Ne güzel de
yaratmış diyorum Aradan birkaç gün
geçiyor hava böyle kapalı modunu düşüp
aynaya bakıyorum ya Çünkü atırsız
ediyorum
en çok güldüğünüz buna daha çok
bildiğiniz
ya neyse yani Ben aynı benim kaşlarım
aynı Kaş ama ne oluyor da bir şekilde
hissiyat değişiyor işte hissiyat dediğim
şey gerçekten bağımsız olabiliyor en
büyük engel lerimizden birisi bu çünkü
his yap çocukluktan getirdiğimiz olumsuz
yükler bir diğer şey ise büyük resmi
anlamak dediğimiz bir mevzu var büyük
resmi anlamak dediğiniz mevzu şu hayatta
bir sürü şey değiştirmeye çalışırken
ortaya kendimize Çabalar koyuyoruz ama
yaptığımız çabaların ne kadar işe
yaradığını hiçbir zaman fark etmiyoruz
bu fark edebilmek için şöyle bir şey
Örnek vermek istiyorum aslan bir ekonomi
prensibi olan harita kuralı denen bir
kural var bu Kural diyor ki hayatta ki
dünyada üretilen mesela paranın üretilen
diyorum dünyada var olan paranın yüzde
sekseni insanların yüzde 20'sine ait
bunu insan davranışını uyarladı kları
zaman şunu fark ediyorlar hayatta ortaya
koyduğumuz başarılarının yüzde sekseni
ortaya koyduğumuz çaba
O yüzden 20'sinden ortaya çıkıyor yani
biz ortaya 101'in bir başarı koyduğumuz
zaman çaba koyduğumuz zaman bu ortaya
koyduğumuz çabanın sekseni boşa gidiyor
ama o 20'nin hangi 20 değerli 20
olduğunu anlayabilmek çok ama çok önemli
sonrasında bir bakıyorsun ki insanlar
Atı alan Üsküdar'ı geçerken birisi iş
hayatında kendini değiştirmek yükselmek
için hamur pointin folklor ile
uğraşırken öbür anlatıyor yapıyor Hadi
hayata geçiriyor yurt taraf hala bir
şeylerin ayrıntılarında boğuluyor ve
böyle olunca hayatın akışı içerisinde o
büyük Resmi görmemiz mümkün olmuyor ve
sonrasında Yüzleşme korkusu dediğimiz
bir şey var ben şuna İnandım o kadar çok
insanla karşılaşınca ve şunu fark
ediyorsunuz insan aciz bir varlık insan
nerede güçlü olduğunu anlarsa ve nerede
güçsüz olduğunu anlarsak tam anlamıyla o
zaman gerçek potansiyeline ulaşabiliyor
İşte o eksikliklerini keşfetti
ama ben nerede zayıfım ben nerede
güçlüyüm dediği zaman işte o zaman bu
engeli fark edebilir Ama insanların
birçoğu kendisiyle yüzleşiyor
sorumluluklarını almıyor başına gelen
şeyler için Etrafındaki insanları
suçlamaya başlıyor ve böyle olunca ne
oluyor aynen bu görselde gördüğünüz gibi
Sıradağlar gözümüzde büyümeye başlıyor
ve bir şekilde O engelleri aşmak git
gide zorlaşıyor sonrasında bu
engellerden bahsettik Aynen arkamda
gördüğünüz görseldeki gibi bir köprü
bizi bekliyor Ben bu köprüye girdim
Köprüsü diyorum Yalnız bu köprü
bildiğimiz anlamda köprülere benzemiyor
Bu köprünün farazi olarak büyüğü
özellikleri var ve şöyle düşünün Ben şu
an yuvarlak bir dairenin içindeyim
içinde bulunduğum olumsuz alışkanlıklar
değiştirmeye çalıştım ve bana zarar
veren her şey benim içinde bulunduğu
daire içerisinde ve ben şurada gördüm
ve konforlu daha iyi olabileceğini
düşündüm Ona geçebilmek için bu köprüden
geçmem lazım ama bu köprüye tarih öyle
örnekler vermiş ki çıkan çok az İnsan
gerçekten karşıya geçmeye başlıyor Ben
içinde bulunduğum durumdan sıkıntıdayım
rahatsızım ve diyorum ki ben artık
kendini değiştirmek istiyorum artık
hayatımda bambaşka şeyler yapacağım ne
yapıyorum o köprüye çıkıyorum ama köprü
sihirli konuşmaya başlıyor ne yapıyor
duygusal engeller imizi karşımıza
çıkartıyor Geri dön o aşağılık ve kötü
gördüğün yerde rahatına bak Bir daha da
köprüye gelmesini istemiyoruz burada
diyor sonra diyor ki büyük resmi anlamak
konusunda ama Beyhan diyor sen daha
yapman gereken bir sürü bir sürü iş
vardı onları hallettim öyle geldi
köprüye diyor Bazen de ne diyor sen
diyor yapamazsın eksikliklerini
halletmem lazım Burası öbür tarafta kötü
insanlar var Sen kendi yerine çok iyisin
o yüzden boş ver o eski haline geri dön
o girdim köprüsüne
çok az insan katlanabiliyor ve Onun
sözünden bir şekilde etkilenip Eski
olumsuz alışkanlıklarımıza dönmeye devam
ediyoruz sonrasında köprü dediğim gibi
zorlu bir süreç ve Ama bu köprü geçen
Bazı insanlar var Nedir bu insanların
yaptığı diye düşündüğümüz zaman bu Uzun
Bir Yol benim yine bu konuda söylenecek
onlarca şey var anlatılacak günlerce şey
var karşılaştığım dört tane şeyden
bahsetmek istiyorum sizlere birincisi
Özellikle bizim toplumumuza bu
toprakları özel bir şey var biz gaza
gelmeyi çok seviyoruz hayatta
değiştirmeye çalıştığımız her şeyi sanki
bir yüz metre koşusu uyumuş gibi
değerlendiriyoruz gaza geleceğim her gün
her şeyi yapacağım kocaman adımlar
atacağım ama benim attığım adımlar ben
sana 35 yaşında 35 yıllık bir sisteme
karşı koymak zorunda ve ne olacak 100
metre koşusuna Çıktığım zaman çok kısa
bir süre içerisinde yorulmuş olacak ama
insan kendisini değiştirmek
ve bu yolun bir maraton koşusu olduğunun
farkına varması lazım adım adım
ilerleyecek sin yavaş yavaş ilerleyecek
sinki vazgeçmesin sonrasında yol devam
ediyor Burada gördüğünüz gibi ne oluyor
Küçük adımlar dediğimiz bir şey Biz
dediğim gibi gaza gelmeyi seviyoruz
istersen ders çalışma konusunu düşün
istersen kendini herhangi bir konuda
kitap okumak konusunda geliştirmek gibi
bir konuda düşün ya da sana zarar veren
insanlarla ilişkine düzenlemek gibi bir
konuyu düşün ne yaparsan yap her zaman
küçük adımlarla başlaman lazım küçük
adamlar bizi büyük hedeflere ulaştıran
en büyük şeylerden birisi kitap okumak
mı istiyorsun 5 sayfayla başla Bir
ilişkide kendine sınır mı koymak
istiyorsun insanlara Hayır mı demek
istiyorsun minicik şeylerle denemelerle
başla Öyle olunca yoluna devam edeceksin
sonrasında ve Bazen o biraz önce
bahsettiğim ayrıntılarda boğulan
insanlar var ya bir sürü şey detaylarda
takılıp Aslında harekete geçirmeyen
insanlari
bu insanlar ne yapıyor hazır olmayı
bekliyor şunu yaparsam harekete
geçeceğim bunu elde edersem harekete
geçeceğim derken bu mükemmel bir planı
Beklerken harekete geçme nokta hiçbir
zaman önümüze gelmiyor yola çıkamıyoruz
Ama şöyle bir bakın Etrafınıza kendinize
kendi geçmişiniz Eğer ki birşey başarmış
sanız hazır olmadan başarmışsındır yola
çıkarsanız eksikliklerimizi oldu
keşfedersiniz ve yolda kendinizi
geliştirirsiniz ne yaparsanız yapın öbür
türlü beklerseniz o yol hiçbir zaman
bitmeyecek ve son olarak insan yola
çıktığı zaman Evet iki adım ileri
gidecek ve sonrasında doğal olarak bir
adım geri gideceksiniz bu insanın
doğasında her türlü değişimde karşımıza
çıkan bir şey nedir bu bu şekilde çaba
gösterdiğimiz zaman o girdim
Köprüsü'nden geçerken bazen yorulacağız
ama bazen kendimizi başarısız
hissedeceğiz bazen bıktım hissedeceğiz
böyle durumlarda Ya ben başaramıyorum
bitiremiyorum dediğin anda bırakma
yolunda olacaksın ama şunu bilirsen bu
insanın duası iki adam ileri gidersin
bir adım geri gidersin Bu sana özel
değil senin başarısız olduğunu
söylemiyor sadece insanın duası İnsanın
hem acziyeti hem de gücü Eğer ki Böyle
zamanlarda bırakmazsan yorulduğu zaman
vazgeçmek yerine dinlenir Sen bu yol
devam ediyor Peki de işim bitiyor mu
bitmiyor bir ömür sürüyor sonra gelirken
şunu söylemek istiyorum sizlere ben
şöyle düşünüyorum Bir insanın yeteneği
varsa bir konuda yeteneği olduğuna
inanıyorsa hayalleri varsa ve Bence
eminim buradaki birçok insanın
mı böyle hayallerine ya da yetenekleri
olduğuna inandığını düşünüyorum şunu
söyleyeceğim size Lanetli siniz
bu kesiti lanet misiniz Ne demek bu
biliyor musunuz bunu kullanmadığınız
zaman bir şekilde o İçinizde sizin
içinizi yiyip bitirecek yapsam var ya Ne
yapardın diye kendi kendini sorgulayacak
sın bir ömür boyu Ben aslında daha
iyisine layıkmışım daha iyisini
hakediyordum diye kendini hep alacaksın
günün birinde geçmişe döndü baktığın
zaman için şurada bir huzursuzluk
kaplayacak O yüzden eğer bir yeteneğin
varsa onu kullanmak zorundasın ya da
öbür türlü ben bu hayata layık
değilimdir kendi kendini yemek
zorundasın O yüzden yeteneğin varsa
kullanacaksın arkadaş başka bir çaresi
yok ve bunu dinledikten sonra belki
aklının bir köşesinde şöyle bir durum
çıkacak ya yapmalıyım harekete
geçmeliyim Evet bu güzel Biz genelde bu
tarz konuşmaların hepsinde buna benzer
şeyler hisler çıkar insan birazcık
harekete geçme noktasında kapının
aralandı ını görür ama sadece
Evet etimiz var Eğer Önümüzdeki 72 saat
içinde harekete geçmezsek minicik de
olsa Kendimiz için bir adım atmazsak
Sonra hayatımız aynı tas aynı hamam
şeklinde devam edecek Eğer ki değişmek
istiyorsan şimdi başlayacaksın yarın
değil sonraki gün değil ya da ileride
bir zaman değil elimdekilerle
başlayacaksın bir şekilde yola
çıkacaksın Çünkü Hayat mücadele üzerine
kurgulanmıştır teşekkür ederim